I want to tell you a secret that will
see you through all the trials that life
can offer have courage and be
kind she'll merely be your stepmother
and you'll have two lovely sisters to
keep you company so I'll know as far
away as I may be that you'll be safe
wouldn't you prefer to eat when all the
work is done ER yes de mother oh you
didn't call me that Madam will do cinder
wench dirty Ella
Cinderella wa whoa whoo are you all
right Miss what did they call you never
mind what they call me I'm sorry it's
not your doing nor yours either Al Bet I
hope to see you again miss and I
you Ella you have more kindness in your
little finger than than most people
possess in their whole body it was my
mother's old dress it would be an insult
to take you to the Palace dressed in
these old rags you shall not go to the
ball excuse me why are you crying who
are
you that's better my fairy go
mother now where is
mice
they're made of glass and you find
they're really comfortable now if you go
for you shall go to the
ball they're all looking at you believe
me they're all looking at
you where there is kindness there is
goodness and where there is goodness
there is
Magic
I have to see her
again are you looking for
this